[Musique]
c'est par cette porte il y as exactement
soixante quinze ans le 4 décembre 1944
que les soldats canadiens sont entrés
dans ravel libérant la ville italienne
des forces nazies
aujourd'hui la population de ravenne
souligner le sacrifice des combattants
canadiens dont plusieurs centaines sont
morts dans les environs la famille de
guy docce rogne a même accueilli un
soldat canadien pendant plusieurs
semaines en 1944 pour me frotter les
canadiens étaient comme des frères pour
nous dit il parce qu'ils nous ont
traités comme des frères et non comme
une nation conquise sur la place
centrale de la ville comme tous les ans
le mage a été rendu à ceux qui ont
contribué à libérer la ville
aujourd'hui sur la liste du patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité de l'unesco
mais cette année 75e anniversaire oblige
ça s'est fait en présence d'une
importante délégation canadienne
on ne veut pas répéter les erreurs du
passé parce qu'on veut aussi honorer
ceux qui ont sacrifié leur vie ou qui en
sont qui ont combattu pour nous pour les
libertés les droits que nous avons
aujourd'hui la campagne d'italie menée
par les forces alliées du canada de la
grande-bretagne et de la france libre a
commencé en juillet 1943 et a duré vingt
mois l'italie qu'on appelait à l'époque
le ventre mou de l'europe fasciste
alliée de l'allemagne nazie ne s'est pas
rendue facilement
éclipsé par le spectaculaire
débarquement en normandie
les combats pour libérer la péninsule
ont pourtant été dur
joseph amable dubé 93 ans s'en souvient
très bien le têt deuxième fois le baiia
le pkk hoyaux d'onofrio bataille c'était
venu parce que les fleurs de liberté de
paix de démocratie étaient entrés dans
leur coeur au cimetière militaire de
ravenne 15 anciens combattants
représente aujourd'hui les 93 mille
jeunes soldats canadiens qui se sont
battus sur cette terre quatre cent
trente huit d'entre eux sont enterrés
ici loin de leurs familles le ministre
des anciens combattants laurence
macaulay s'est recueilli sur la tombe de
l'un d'entre eux je suis pas de talent
que tu es libérateur
il n'oublie valeurs de liberté et de
justice dans son discours le maire de
ravenne a remercié les garçons de 1944
comme il les a appelés âgés de 17 à 39
ans anglophones et francophones qui sont
venus se battre ici pour les valeurs de
liberté et de justice
[Musique]
ces commémorations sont d'autant plus
importantes que les derniers témoins de
la fin du fascisme sont en train de
disparaître et avec eux la mémoire de ce
qui fut une immense tragédie pour des
millions de gens à travers le monde et
parmi eux les 6000 canadiens morts sur
cette terre italienne
il y à 75 ans ici alexandra schatz qu'à
radio-canada à ravenne en italie